night city
is a dangerous place if you aren't well
equipped your legend could end
before it even begins in this video
we're going to explain the benefit of
iconic weapons
where to find them and how to upgrade
them make sure to like and subscribe
for more cyberpunk tips
cyberpunk 2077 like many modern looter
shooters has a tiered loot system
white is common green is uncommon blue
is rare purple is epic and orange is
legendary
separate from a gun's rarity though is
whether or not it's iconic
for example the dying knight pistol
wilson returns to you at the beginning
of the game
is an uncommon iconic pistol iconic
weapons unlike legendary or epic ones
can only be found once in the game
this means that even when an iconic
weapon has seemingly become useless
it's in your best interest to hold on to
it even if that means dumping it in your
trunk or
weapons cash we'll get into how to
upgrade them later in the video
apart from their unique design iconic
weapons typically come with an array of
extra buffs and perks
some come with built-in silencers while
others may have special
melee attacks if you find an iconic
weapon
be sure to check out its description and
stats in the inventory menu as its perks
may not always be
obvious the next question you probably
have is where do i find iconic weapons
we have a guide on gamespot that breaks
down where to get a handful of these
prized firearms but generally it's by
completing side quests
there are a couple of key characters
that will give you an iconic weapon for
completing their optional quest lines
like river and pan am
while others you might find as you
progress through the story without
spoiling too much one of my favorite
iconic weapons in the game
can only be acquired by helping johnny
in the quest called chipping in
so keep an eye out for that one once
you've found an iconic weapon that you
like you might be wondering how to keep
it relevant as you level up and face off
against tougher enemies the good news is
that every iconic weapon you find
comes with all of its crafting
blueprints the amount of times you can
craft a better version of an iconic
weapon it depends on the rarity you find
it at
so these uncommon iconic pistol you get
at the start of the game can be crafted
three times
uncommon to rare rare to epic and epic
to legendary
of course if you want to craft a better
version of an iconic weapon
you'll need weapon upgrade parts which
can be found throughout the world
purchased from vendors or by dismantling
non-iconic weapons you don't need
on top of that you'll need perks that
let you craft rare epic and legendary
items
like weapons upgrade parts also come in
the form of tiered loot
common uncommon rare epic and legendary
in order to upgrade an iconic epic
weapon to an iconic legendary weapon
you'll need legendary weapon parts
the easiest way to get legendary weapon
parts is to buy them
or break down legendary weapons you
don't need if you've been investing in
v's technical ability attribute there
are perks that net you more weapon
components for each weapon you break
down
additionally you can also upgrade an
iconic weapon this slightly improves a
weapon without
upping its rarity as you'd expect this
also requires weapon components
any type of v can upgrade a weapon but
only a v with a prowess and technical
ability can craft higher tier weapons
this means that even if you have the
blueprint and all the components to
craft a better version of an iconic
weapon
you won't have the know-how to do so
unless you've invested in some of the
technical ability perks
if you plan on spending a lot of time
crafting and upgrading weapons
i highly recommend perusing the
technical ability skill trees
there are a ton of iconic weapons to
find in night city so keep your eyes and
ears open
even simple quests could yield some
awesome rewards
if there's an iconic weapon that you
really like let us know in the comments
below and for more on cyberpunk 2077
stay tuned to gamespot
[Applause]
you